hello hello hello welcome to another
episode of
revisiting my personal hell for your
amusement
guys this is the start of an accidental
live stream
on thursday in case you missed it two
hours
and 16 minutes of this could have been
so much worse i'm happy to report that i
was basically just fixing a mic stand
but you cannot imagine the horror when
later i go out to dinner and i'm just
live streaming this
i get this text what is this live stream
no signal i say what live stream can i
get texted from another friend
you know you're live right i say
uh no and immediately panic because i'm
thinking
okay what did i do on the stream because
i must have accidentally pressed
go live i'm thinking did i accidentally
you know
reveal my dark secret did i accidentally
show my tolkien fan fiction
it was a long ride home i like to
imagine the emotions i was feeling was
something like what mr tubin must have
been feeling when he was uh
suddenly realized he had been live now
of course i wasn't doing anything like
that
but i was pissed because of susan
susan and jeff if you stream on twitch
they're out here trying to catch you
slipping is what i realized i started
doing some research
guys do you realize that streaming live
to all your fans is a one click
it's a all i have to do is press on obs
a little
start streaming button here i'll put it
right here start streaming
that's it and then i'm live to
everyone and that's what happened i was
adjusting my mic
and it just hit go live and all of a
sudden i'm live in front of
you know tens of thousands of people i
don't know how many people tuned in
probably probably millions now you might
be asking yourself what kind of
user design experience doesn't ask hey
are you sure you want to go live
to your entire audience right now that's
what you would think they would do
and pretty quickly i came to one
conclusion
hey i better do something about this so
i went to the office
and got to work and i realized that i
was far from the only person this has
happened to
i mean apparently this happens to
streamers all the time
there's a whole category on youtube
called accidentally went live of all the
youtubers who
accidentally go live and embarrass
themselves on camera
because it's so easy to go live
on accident it's happened to ninja it's
happened to
pokemane look at this guy omg chad he
was asleep
his cat pressed the button on his stream
deck and then a bunch of people called
him but imagine
the stuff that could have happened at
best it's embarrassing
at worst it's career ending all because
of the terrible design of
going live but my motto is fool me once
shame on susan fooled me twice shame on
me so i was determined
to create a solution not just for me but
also for streamers
everywhere i feel like i want to create
like a puppy commercial
like every day a streamer's life is
ruined
i literally didn't mean to click start
streaming by an accidental live stream
turn you guys remember this guy darkseid
phil
this is like the worst thing that can
happen to you uh
or people like jeffrey tubin on zoom i
mean you know i call it the
getting me tubing you get caught tugging
the tubing
every day a streamer's life gets ruined
by a me tubing moment
and because of that i created
this product i call it the tube and
switch
it's a little script i wrote in obs to
prevent you
from having these embarrassing things
happen to you whenever you go live it
automatically switches
to a warning scene of your choosing this
is the one i created it starts with a
news alert of jeffrey toobin then it
goes into the candid camera intro
uh with full music so you know that
you're live
[Music]
so if that doesn't already get your
attention there gets to be this tube and
switch
counter that automatically starts it's a
timer of your choosing
and if you have not clicked off of this
scene within
obs by the time that it's run down
automatically obs stops streaming so
it's basically a dead man switch
if you accidentally press it if your cat
accidentally presses it at five in the
morning
it puts you on some innocuous scene like
this and then by the time the timer runs
down
it just gets you out of the live stream
now i know what you're saying to
yourself
okay stephen cool cool cool program you
made
uh how much does it cost good question
because you know as well as i do as dan
lok says if you're good at something
don't do it for free so at first i was
thinking to myself how much should i
charge for this how much
would people like ninja pokemane
pay to not lose their career from
getting me tube and
it's a good question how much would you
pay for the peace of mind
so first i was thinking millions but
then i thought no steven you can't
do that to the coffeezilla army they got
you here
they want better than that so i said
maybe i'll bring it down to 100k
maybe bring it down by 90 and still i
felt
bad i felt it's a little expensive
so today limited time
supply there's only so many of these
that can go around
i am offering this e-product
not at 99 off not at 99.9 percent off
which is a bargain already
at a thousand dollars but
i'm offering it for a hundred percent
off with
the purchase of a twitter follow and a
youtube subscription
show those at checkout in the link below
and you will get
this product absolutely free
yeah i know i know i'm giving i'm giving
it all away i'm giving my secrets away
so bye now because i don't want what
happened to me to happen to you
don't let susan catch you slipping see
ya and don't forget to smash like
and subscribe thank you